Poland has become the first of Ukraine's
allies to commit to sending key fighter
jets Polish president Andre dudas says
Warsaw will deliver four MiG-29 Jets and
full working order in the coming days
with more to come once they're checked
Ukraine has been asking the West for
jets for months to help its defensive
efforts let's bring in our correspondent
Stephanie Decker she's joining us from
Kiev so as we said Stephanie Ukraine has
been asking for these fighter jets for
months so how significant is the Pledge
from Poland what are they saying about
it
yes well Ukraine's really been asking
for jets since the beginning of the war
it's significant of course it is it's
the first time a NATO Ally Ukrainian
Ally says that it is going to send now
you mentioned there for mig-29s there
will be more in the next coming days
interestingly Poland's prime minister
yesterday saying that they were going to
send Jets but within four to six weeks
so a very quick Utah now a commitment of
immediate uh it's it seems delivering
them in the next uh coming days it's
something that the Allies have been
discussing it's something that Keith's
been asking for for a very long time it
is certainly a step up in the commitment
of its allies when it comes to providing
Weaponry it's also seeing the arrival of
some of the leopard tanks and from
Poland as well and nine other countries
particularly also mentioned by the U.S
Secretary of uh defense yesterday
um Secretary of State
um Lloyd Austin saying nine countries
committing to sending around 150 leopard
tanks to Ukraine and they will be
arriving before the end of March the
timing of all of this is very
interesting of course because there's a
lot of talk that Ukraine is planning a
counter-offensive uh as the weather is
getting warmer as the ground is thawing
um to push Russia further back there's a
real severe lack of ammunition and
weaponry if you will the weapons
manufacturers that have been supplying
uh Ukraine particularly also the
Americans saying that this war is is is
firing through the ammunition quicker
than the weapon suppliers can supply
them so it's not only the bigger weapons
that we're talking about like like tanks
and aircraft it's also things like
shells and ammunitions uh that are much
needed on the ground so certainly this
is a welcome move from Poland it will be
welcomed here in Kiev and again a lot of
the Allies saying that they're
discussing uh ramping up even further
support and would the war come countless
human rights violation Stephanie in the
Human Rights Council has just released
the details of its investigation into
those violations what have they
determined
yes this is the most powerful tool if
you will at the hands of the Human
Rights Commission they've been looking
into allegations of war crimes committed
by the Russians what they've said as
many of those do amount to war crimes
even some of them could be crimes
against humanity citing incidents like
attacks against civilian infrastructure
attacks against the the power supply uh
torture not protecting the civilian
population and as far as again torture
rapes sexual abuse of many different
kinds and saying that these need to be
investigated the commission doesn't have
any power if you will to hold anything
to account but it's uh believed in its
hoped that this kind of Investigation
will then add to the paperwork that you
have also being carried out by the
international criminal court at the
moment that recently announced that it
would be looking into opening a case
against Russia when it came to cases of
potential War crime citing things like
again attacks against civilian
infrastructure and also the forcible
deportation of children of Ukrainian
children to Russia so a lot of files on
the table you also have the Ukrainian
Chief prosecutor looking into
allegations of war crimes particularly
things like sexual abuse and rape these
are things that are very difficult to
investigate because of the stigma
attached because of the shame attached
to the victims and they find it very
hard to come forward but a lot of these
cases are now in process being
investigated data being collected
to certainly at some point uh ukrainians
will tell you hopefully come to some
form of legal action holding
perpetrators to account looking in the
past we know is very very difficult but
certainly these are all steps in the
right direction another Stephanie Decker
with the latest developments from
Ukraine live in Kiev thank you Stephanie